do voter legislation laws ensure secure
and trustworthy elections or are they a
way for political parties to manipulate
the democratic process in their favor at
a september 8 debate in new york city
hosted by the soho forum eliza
swarenbecker from nyu's brennan center
for justice argued that state
legislators are using arbitrary rules to
suppress the voting rights of vulnerable
citizens the heritage foundation's hans
von spakovsky countered that these rules
are necessary to guarantee that every
vote cast is valid noting that in states
where voter id laws already exist
registration rates have risen this was
an oxford style debate in which the
audience voted before and after the
event to see which side swayed more
people it was moderated by soho forum
director gene epstein
legislators in multiple states are
actively making making it harder for
americans to vote
defending the resolution eliza swearin
becker eliza please come to the stage
opposing and taking the negative on the
resolution hans von spakovsky
hans please come to the stage
it's okay it's okay
it's okay eliza you can sit there
because you are coming to the podium
right now to defend the resolution you
have 15 minutes take it away eliza
hello everyone
it's nice to be with people in person
and thank you so much for the
introduction and and thank you all for
being here in person
in last year's general election voters
turned out in historic numbers and used
male and early voting at unprecedented
levels
presidential election turnout was seven
percentage points higher than in 2016
and the number of ballots cast by mail
or in person before election day more
than doubled that of 2016. that is good
news for american democracy
but the response for many state houses
across the country has been clear
by july at least 18 states had enacted
30 laws that make it harder to vote
and more have been signed since
the reality is actually worse than those
numbers suggest because states like
georgia florida iowa and texas
have enacted omnibus bills that contain
multiple restrictions
the brennan center has been tracking
state voting legislation for more than a
decade decade excuse me i get a little
winded these days
um
this is without a doubt the biggest wave
of new laws to make voting harder that
we have seen in recent memory it cannot
reasonably just be disputed that many
state legislators across the country
you guys can hear me okay
thanks
it cannot reasonably be disputed that
many state legislators across the
country are actively working to make it
harder for americans to vote
first when you actually look at the text
of these laws it's clear they put
barriers in the path of eligible voters
on the way to the ballot box
second
studies show that these kinds of
restrictions burden american voters and
in particular voters of color
third there's a tightness of fit problem
supporters of these new restrictions
argue that they are necessary to protect
the integrity of american elections to
prevent voter fraud or at a minimum to
restore public confidence in our
elections
but the laws don't largely improve
american elections
and that's because study after studies
show that our elections are not actually
plagued by fraud
in other words the downside is big these
new laws impose greater costs and
burdens on voters in some cases
decreasing turnout but the upside is nil
that is a bum deal for american voters
and american democracy
taking those three steps in turn let's
first look at these new laws and i won't
describe every feature of the dozens of
laws that have been enacted this year
but starting first with florida for
example
the state's omnibus legislation sb90
strictly limits the availability of mail
ballot drop boxes which have been used
in the state for many years without
incident
these boxes are now accessible only at
certain government offices
but that's not withstanding the fact
that mail ballots can be dropped off at
any blue mail excuse me blue mailbox on
the corner 24 hours a day seven days a
week
so why did florida lawmakers decide to
make it harder for voters to access
dropboxes
it seems like the popularity of these
boxes might have something to do with it
during the 2020 general election at
least 51 of florida's 67 counties
offered a dropbox that was available 24
7
and as a result 1.5 million floridian
voters used a dropbox to vote making up
more than 10 percent of voters overall
and more than a quarter excuse me
and more than a quarter of those who
voted by mail
it's also worth noting that the
percentage of black voters who cast
their ballots by mail doubled in florida
from 2016 to 2020.
state policies that make it harder to
vote in florida are not new
in 2019 after the state voters adopted a
constitutional amendment to restore
voting rights to people with past
convictions the state enacted a law
conditioning eligibility on the
repayment of court debts arising from
criminal convictions
in other words for hundreds of thousands
of floridians the only thing determining
whether they can vote is the balance in
their bank account
expert analysis has found that this
denies eligibility to more than 700 000
floridians who are disproportionately
black
georgia 2 has restricted the
availability in hours of drop boxes
now the four major metro counties
surrounding atlanta will be limited to
an estimated 23 boxes total by contrast
there were 111 such boxes last year and
more than 300 000 voters used them
to put that into context the
presidential race was decided in georgia
by less than 12 000 votes
george's omnibus law also prohibits
election officials from affirmatively
sending out mail ballot applications to
voters gives voters less time to apply
for absentee ballots and criminalizes
the act of giving snacks and water to
voters waiting in line at polling places
it's hard to see how any of these
policies has anything to do with
improving our elections but it's easy to
see how they incrementally make it
harder to vote
most recently texas enacted omnibus
legislation as well the law bans 24-hour
early voting locations drive-through
voting and mobile polling place
structures
without any basis for why these
conveniences could undermine our
elections
the law makes it a crime for public
officials to encourage voters who may be
eligible to submit mail ballot
applications yet places no such
restriction on party officials
at the same time the law makes all
voting fraud offenses misdemeanors
instead of felonies which seems like an
especially odd thing to do in a law that
supporters and the texas governor claim
was designed to discourage such
such misconduct
in iowa sf-413 shortens the early voting
period by nine days and limits election
officials discretion to offer additional
early voting locations
why in alabama hb 285 prohibits curbside
voting entirely an essential voting
method for voters with disabilities
one of the bill's supporters in the
assembly there claimed that the law was
intended to ensure that there was no
fraud in that voting procedure even as
he acknowledged that that didn't happen
in alabama last year
i could go on but won't what's clear
from the plain text of these policies is
that these laws add to the hurdles that
voters must overcome to exercise their
fundamental right to vote and that the
purported justification for these rules
is simply pretext
you don't have to take that from me the
proponents of these restrictions have
said so themselves during supreme court
arguments earlier this year the lawyer
for the arizona republican party
defended arizona's law in validating
votes cast in the wrong precinct by
saying that not having that policy on
the books would put them at a
competitive disadvantage relative to
democrats it's the difference between
winning an election 50 49 and losing an
election
similarly an arizona lawmaker when
justifying new restrictions in the
state's mail voting process this year
stated that quote everybody shouldn't be
voting and quote the quality of votes
mattered and when discussing proposals
to expand access to male voting last
year president trump stated that an
expansion of early and male voting would
lead to quote levels of voting that if
you agreed to it you'd never have a
republican elected in the country again
second a mountain of research shows that
these kinds of voting restrictions do
indeed burden voters and make it harder
to vote particularly for racial
minorities and other groups like voters
with disabilities
on one hand data show that measures that
make voting more convenient like
increasing the proximity of voting
locations adding more voting days
those things matter to voters and to
turnout
voters surveyed as to why they didn't
vote in the 2018 midterm elections for
example most commonly responded that it
was because they were quote too busy and
had a conflicting schedule
others cited an inconvenient polling
place while others said they faced
transportation problems
that's why reforms that make it more
convenient to vote have been shown to
increase turnout for example one
peer-reviewed study showed that for
every additional early voting day in
ohio turnout increased by a quarter of a
percentage point and that joins other
research showing the positive effects of
early voting on turnout
enacting no excuse mail voting has been
shown to increase turnout by between one
and two percent
and studies show that mail voting
especially increases turnout for younger
voters voters of color voters with less
education and voters with disabilities
on the other hand the inverse is true
policies that make it less convenient to
vote decrease turnout
a 2017 study of a local new york
election found that polling place
consolidation decreased voter turnout
substantially by about seven percent
in a 2020 study of cities in minnesota
and and massachusetts found that
increasing voters travel distance to the
polls by a quarter mile decreased the
number of ballots by two to five percent
across four elections
a 2021 study indicates that every hour
spent waiting in line reduces
turnout in subsequent elections by about
one percent
and other studies demonstrate that wait
times and polling place closures
disproportionately affect black and
latino voters
notwithstanding all of this data many
states are going backwards by enacting
laws that make it harder to vote by mail
make dropboxes harder to access make
polling places less convenient and cut
early voting days
additionally several states have imposed
harsher voter id requirements this year
including georgia florida texas montana
and arkansas
yet there is no data showing a
correlation between voter id
requirements and the occurrence or
prevention of fraud
what the research does show in
peer-reviewed studies is that strict
voter id laws decrease turnout
for example after north carolina adopted
a strict voter id law in 2013
researchers at stanford found that
voters who lacked id
turned out in fewer numbers and that
turnout effect continued even after an
appellate court struck down that strict
id law a study published last year
showed that the adoption of strict voter
id in alabama mississippi virginia and
wisconsin caused turnout to decline by
about one percent by more than one
percentage point an effect size larger
than the presidential vote margin in
many states
other work shows that people of color
are less likely to have the required id
and that strict voter id laws
disproportionately reduce non-white
turnout
let me pause here to emphasize that
overall voter turnout is not the only
thing that matters
in fact
focusing exclusively on overall turnout
numbers can gloss over the way that
changing voting rules affects racial
minorities and other subgroups
voting restrictions can change who votes
in a given jurisdiction even if they
don't change the overall number of
voters in that area
for example even with historic overall
turnout in 2020 there remains a
significant turnout gap between white
and non-white voters
overall 71 percent of eligible white
voters cast ballots in the 2020 general
elections compared to only 58 percent of
non-white voters
and the racial turnout gap has actually
grown since the 2012 elections notably
the supreme court shelby county decision
came down in 2013 that decision stopped
what's known as pre-clearance which is
the process by which states and
jurisdictions with a history of racial
discrimination and voting had to get
pre-approval for changes to their voting
rules
the evidence is overwhelming that voting
laws do in fact matter
but we shouldn't need a study to tell us
that fair free and equal voting access
is a core democratic value that needs to
be defended and expanded
voting restrictions are harmful even if
they have no impact on overall turnout
putting aside all of the evidence the
intent
intent of these state measures is clear
to make it harder for americans to vote
and it would be strange to argue that
simply because state lawmakers may not
succeed in shutting millions out of the
democratic process they should be able
to continue these efforts unimpeded
whether a given anti-voter policy will
have a large partisan racial or turnout
effect the bottom line is that
restricting access to the ballot is
wrong and inconsistent with a free and
democratic form of government
legislators proposing these changes
because they want to limit the
electorate may continue introducing
these bills until they find something
that works
third and finally state lawmakers and
others have justified the need for new
voting restrictions by pointing to their
desire to protect election integrity and
prevent fraud
but the truth is that extensive research
reveals that the incidence of voter
fraud in contemporary u.s elections is
exceedingly rare voter impersonation is
virtually non-existent and many
instances of alleged fraud are in fact
mistakes by voters or election
administrators
that's the same goes for mail ballots as
it does for voting in person
even taking the heritage foundation's
own database of purported voter fraud
and putting aside mathematical
methodological questions about that
database the organization claims it has
identified
1333 instances of voter fraud
but that's over the course of 40 years
and billions of votes cast in other
words the incidence of fraud is
infinitesimal
indeed president trump's voter fraud
commission was disbanded in 2018 after
failing to find evidence supporting
to support widespread claims of fraud
it is not an accident that we don't see
widespread election misconduct in this
country that's because there are many
protections already in place that ensure
the integrity of american elections like
paper ballots poll books ballot bar
codes
mail ballot tracking through usps
penalties for those who commit
misconduct voterless maintenance and
risk limiting audits in other words it's
quite difficult for an individual to
commit fraud and if a person does so the
effect of any one person's misdeed is
necessarily limited
when candidates or officials attempt to
perpetrate more systematic fraud on
voters those schemes are generally
caught for example the north carolina
state board of elections detect
thanks
detected a
consultant's effort to rig a 2018
congressional election
this year the los angeles district
attorney has filed a criminal case
against a candidate for city council who
won his race by a single vote alleging
conspiracy to commit election fraud and
that criminal case is ongoing
in other words our system is working
as i described the downside of imposing
more restrictions on voting is high but
the upside is low
the pop the problem these laws purport
to fix is not a significant risk 30
seconds
it's possible that an asteroid falls to
earth or you get struck by lightning
just like voter fraud as possible but we
don't ask every person to incur the
costs and burdens of buying asteroid or
lightning insurance especially when are
already effective protections in place
to the extent americans have a lack of
confidence in our electoral system that
distrust has been sown by activists
making misrepresentations about fraud
before putting obstacles in the way of
americans exercising their most
fundamental right there should be a good
reason to do so and that reason simply
is not present
rather than instilling mistrust based on
often racialized lies about fraud
lawmakers should be telling the truth
about our elections the department of
homeland security called the 2020
general election
the most secure in american history
even with historic voter turnout this
year voter participation in this country
is not what it should be just two-thirds
of
eligible americans cast ballots last
year
lawmakers should be making working to
make it easier for americans to vote
freely and fairly not relying on
unsubstantiated claims of voter fraud to
burden voters our democracy is more
accountable and more representative when
every eligible american participates
thank you
[Applause]
speaking speaking for the negative
take it away hands i guess you get an
extra 60 seconds
to speak for the negative
well it is nice to see people in person
it's been a while since i've been able
to do that because of zoom and
everything else so
it's nice to have an audience here today
i do want to before i start just very
quickly thank the reason foundation
thank gene thank the soho forum
because one thing that we have seen
unfortunately in this country is a
steady erosion of the ability to have
civil debates
even about contentious issues and i
applaud the soho forum for continuing
what i think is a great american
tradition that is in sad decline
especially
on american campuses
second i want to emphasize something
that i learned from my immigrants
immigrant parents who experienced some
of the worst dictatorships of the last
century and that is voting is the
essential ingredient
in maintaining and protecting our
democratic republic and the liberty and
freedom we enjoy as citizens
our goal should be to ensure that every
eligible citizen
is able to vote but we also have to
safeguard that vote so that it is not
voided or stolen through fraud errors
mistakes or other problems
we do have an obligation to it to ensure
fair and secure elections and that
should be a bipartisan goal
regardless of
actually with the reason foundation
should be a tripartisan goal
regardless of what political party based
support
the mistake that opponents of election
reform make
is that they believe you cannot
guarantee both access and security and
that is wrong
you can have both and if you talk to
members of the public you will find they
want both access and security
now the claim that there's been a wave
of voter suppression going on across the
country
for the past decade
that's when these claims first started
this first started in 2005
more than a decade ago when states like
indiana and georgia passed some of the
first
photo id laws requirements for
elections um it's false because the
efforts to improve the integrity of the
election process whether it's requiring
an id and keep in mind
every single state that has put in an id
requirement provides a free id
to anyone who doesn't already have one
and that
one requirement is overwhelmingly
supported by americans
all the polling shows whether it's
liberal polls or conservative polls
americans overwhelmingly support that
they think it's a common sense
requirement and it doesn't matter
what party they support it doesn't
matter what their color or ethnic
background is
and it's no doubt because they have to
show an id almost every day in
everything they do from boarding a plane
to going to the pharmacy to seeing a
doctor to cashing a check to buying
alcohol
now
in states that have put in measures like
voter id and keep in mind
what i just said the first voter id laws
in georgia and indiana were in effect in
the 2008 election so we've got more than
a decade's worth of data turnout data
from those states to show what it does
not only did turnout not go down
including of minority of voters in those
states in fact it went up
there's also been a steady decrease
in enforcement enforcement actions by
the u.s justice department
okay i used to work there i used to work
in the civil rights division whose
responsibility is enforcing the voting
rights act
okay the most powerful tool in the
voting rights act is section two
of the act it's a permanent nationwide
provision
it prohibits racial discrimination and
voting
and you would think obviously that if
there was voter suppression going on
that's the term created
by opponents of election reform
the justice department would be busy
filing suits
because the whole point supposedly voter
suppression is to keep for example
racial minorities from voting
the obama administration i'm sure you
would agree would not exactly be shy
about using the tools of the justice
department including the voting rights
act
yet in the entire eight years
of the obama administration they only
filed four
enforcement actions under section two of
the voting rights act claiming that a
state or jurisdiction was engaging in
racial discrimination the trump
administration in four years filed too
so basically it was the same rate
uh if there was this huge wave of voter
suppression going on and there was
actual evidence
that measures like voter id were keeping
people from voting
lawsuits would have been filed about all
of these
let me make a quick point about georgia
to just give you an example of this
georgia passed a voter id law first
effective in the 2008 election a lawsuit
was filed against it
the lawsuit was eventually dismissed
with once after one slight change in the
law
the judge in the case
who was a democratic nominee
said that after two years of litigation
the plaintiffs in that case including
the aclu were unable to come up with a
single witness who would be unable to
vote because of the georgia voter id law
and it's been in place ever since and
they've seen record registration and
turnout in the state in fact in the
first election
this is the official turnout numbers
the turnout of black voters in the state
of georgia in 2008 compared to 2004 when
there was no voter id law in place
had a percentage increase of 140 percent
hispanic turnout went up 42
white's turnout went up 8
in 2010
congressional elections barack obama not
on the ballot
compared to 2006 when there was no voter
id in place black turnout went up 66.5
percent hispanic turnout went up over 44
white turnout went up 11 now when i cite
those figures for 2008 about the huge
increase in turnout
in georgia in fact they had record
turnout people say well of course
barack obama was on the ballot that's
true we had a big increase in turnout
across the country but in fact
the democratic turnout in 2008
in the general election
in georgia
was 6.1 percentage points which was the
fifth largest increase in the nation
far above other states like new york
which has no voter id law
the overall turnout in the general
election in georgia in the 2008
election
it went up 6.7 percentage points over
the prior election the second largest
increase in the country
indiana the same thing happened remember
indiana
put in a voter id law it was in place
for the first time in 2008
democratic turnout in the state was up
8.32 percentage points over 2004 when
there was no id
that was the largest increase in
democratic turnout
in the nation
the whole point of this is that the data
actually shows that all these claims
that voter id is going to keep people
from voting is just not true
don't if you doubt me
google a study two years ago from the
national bureau of economic research
they looked at more than a decade's
worth of turnout data in all 50 states
in the district of columbia
and their conclusion
which i quote is
voter id had no negative effect on
registration or turnout overall or for
any specific group defined by race
gender age or party affiliation
now all the extraordinary claims you've
seen about
georgia texas
doing all these terrible things people
keep people out to vote
let me give an example of what was in
the georgia reform that so
outraged uh people in the media and
elsewhere
as i said georgia's had a a voter id law
in place for in-person voting for more
than a decade they've had no problems
they've had big increases in
registration and turnout
so
what happened in the election they had a
huge increase in absentee ballots so
they said well look we really ought to
extend
the id requirement to absentee ballots
made it extraordinarily easy
to comply
when you reply when you apply for an
absentee ballot you simply wrote in
the serial number of your driver's
license or
the serial number of the free id
that they would provide for you and if
you had neither of those
you wrote in the last four digits of
your social security number
and if you didn't have any of that
you could send in a photocopy of a
utility bill bank statement paycheck or
any government document with your name
and address on it
now if that language sounds familiar it
should be because that's a federal
requirement first
put in place in 2002 and to help america
vote act congress passed a law
92 senators voted for including the
current president
that said the first time you registered
a vote
if you vote by mail the first time you
go vote
you have to provide either a picture id
or
a copy of a utility bill bank statement
paycheck or government document that is
what supposedly is keeping people out of
the polls but we know from the numbers
that's just simply not true
um
the other thing to keep in mind is that
many of the other provisions
that people are saying are somehow going
to restrict people to vote when you
actually look at the content of the
bills it's just not the case
one of the things that texas just did
is they said that
they are going to put in
a requirement in large counties to put
in video surveillance
in the locations where votes are being
counted and tabulated
now does anybody think there's actually
something wrong with that
transparency is the heart of having fair
elections
right we want transparency that's why
the u.s state department
sends teams of american observers
to fledgling democracies all over the
world
and yet this is being criticized
as somehow going to keep people from
voting that there's going to be video
surveillance to make sure that
everything's being done the way it
should
they're also criticizing the fact that
texas strengthened its laws on election
observers
now let's make it clear election
observers can do nothing other than
observe
if they interfere with the voting
process they can be ejected from a
polling
place and in fact if they engage in any
kind of intimidation or coercion or
pressure they can be criminally
prosecuted
but you all saw in the last election
observers
being ejected from polling places not
because they had engaged in bad behavior
but to apparently
not allow them to see what's going on or
you saw them play so far back
that they could not effectively see what
was going on
so texas simply has strengthened its law
they've made it very clear
observers cannot interfere with the
election process they can't interfere
with voters but election officials
cannot
simply decide to eject observers out
because they don't want observers there
seeing what they're doing again why
would anybody be against that
that is the kind of thing we want we
want observers of all of the parties
whether it's democrats libertarians
republicans to be able to be in polling
places and not allow election officials
to throw them out
another big
claim that has been constantly made
is that uh when when texas and other
states when they ban what's what people
call vote harvesting
i call it vote trafficking that that's
somehow going to keep people from voting
what does that mean
look you can vote by absentee ballot in
new york
and other states and you can mail your
ballot back depending on the postal
service to get it back for you or you
can personally deliver it yourself a
member of your family can personally
deliver it a designated caregiver can
personally deliver it but in about half
the states
they have a wise policy of banning
third-party strangers from able to come
to your front door
and pick up your ballot and deliver it
why is that a good policy do you really
think it's a good idea for candidates
campaign activists
party uh
volunteers and political guns for hire
to be able to go to voters homes
and pick up their ballots that does two
things one it puts them in a position to
pressure and coerce voters
which has been a problem in texas
they've had
numerous prosecutions there of that
but it also puts them in the
it gives them the ability to handle
something very valuable to them all of
those individuals have a stake in the
outcome of the election
and yet you're giving them ballots
which means that they could potentially
alter or change them which is what
happened in the ninth congressional
district in north carolina in 2018.
that's why more than half a dozen
individuals there were
arrested
because they were collecting absentee
ballots they were in some cases filling
them out altering the choices made by
voters signing them
and the election was overturned one
minute because of that fortunately
um i'm not saying that there is massive
voter fraud in the united states
but there's enough that we should be
concerned about it and that's not just
me saying it it's the u.s supreme court
saying that
in 2008 when they upheld
indiana's voter id law and what the
supreme court said is that
there have been
flagrant examples of such fraud
throughout our history
documented by historians and journalists
and it could make the difference in a
close election
and we have close elections all the time
in this country like
the compton
case that was just mentioned
where half a dozen individuals have been
indicted criminally indicted for using
absentee ballots to apparently steal a
city council election this june
including a city council member who they
wanted to make sure got elected who won
by
one vote
thanks
[Applause]
uh thank you hands and uh five minutes
for rebuttal ellen you can take the
podium if you'd like yeah
thanks and i absolutely agree that
voting access and the security of our
elections are not mutually exclusive
that's why we encourage policies like
automatic voter registration where
voters automatically get registered when
they interact with the dmv for example
unless they opt out
that has been shown to increase
registration numbers in all in the
states that has it has been implemented
and it simultaneously keeps our voter
roles accurate because people's
addresses are updated when they interact
with those
voter registration and government
agencies so that our voter rolls are
accurate and clean
those are not the kinds of policies that
are being introduced and enacted this
year
we heard a lot about voter id
but we didn't hear a lot about all of
the very many policies that make it
harder to vote by mail and then make it
harder to vote early those policies that
that
increase voting methods and make voting
more convenient that have been
conclusively shown to increase turnout
those policies that voters took
advantage of in unprecedented numbers
last year
those are precisely the methods of
voting that have been attacked by new
laws this year by shortening early
voting periods by making it harder to
drop off ballots by making it harder to
obtain an absentee ballot by prohibiting
election officials from sending out
applications
i think it's worth it particularly
touching on texas and the um example of
um the ex strength the quote
strengthening of laws on election
observers
one of the other things that the texas
law did was criminally prohibit the
removal of a poll watcher
unless
an election judge which is a local local
poll worker election official working in
a polling place in texas
personally observes that that watcher
violated texas law
that means that a dozen voters can
report to an election judge working the
polling place that they have been
intimidated by that by a particular
watcher
and that election judge still cannot
remove that watcher
without risking
felony prosecution
i also want to note that we heard we
heard a bit about vote harvesting and
the risks there but just like the risk
of election fraud for voting in person
the risk of committing male
ballot fraud is still more rare than
being struck by lightning
and turning
again to voter id it's true that that
states typically provide those ids for
free um and i have a job many of you may
have jobs where you can run out on your
lunch break and go to the dmv and get a
new license if you've moved to a new
state or get a license for the first
time
but but time isn't free and for many
americans they don't have the ability to
do that so if you don't have that time
if you don't have the accessibility to
get to a dmv or another government
agency if you are a voter with a dis if
you are an american with a disability if
you are a person with limited
transportation access
actually obtaining that identification
is difficult even if financially it
doesn't come at a cost to you
likewise we heard about the georgia law
which requires somebody to submit a copy
of a utility bill if they don't have an
id number of course that requires
somebody to have access to a
photocopying machine and a printer
many of us may have that many of us may
have gained access to that as we've been
working from home over the course of the
last 18 months but for many georgians
that may very well not be accessible so
these are policies that
many of which have been
policies like restricting mail voting
restricting early voting that have been
shown to decrease turnout and to the
extent that these policies don't
decrease overall turnout we've seen that
they disproportionately burden certain
voters who
who rely on methods like mail voting
if you're a voter with disabilities who
don't have access to be able to run over
to a government agency
i've got the one minute
and or who don't have access to a
printer
what is clear is that states even even
in instances where they are not
successful at decreasing voter turnout
or registration
are trying to make it harder for
americans to vote and they have told us
that time and time again
it's important that we push back on that
and realize that these lawmakers should
be trying to make it easier for eligible
americans to to vote rather than trying
to find ways to
go after voting access in death by a
thousand cuts making small changes over
the course of an election code that make
it harder overall for voters to overcome
those burdens burdens that americans
eligible americans shouldn't have to
overcome to exercise their fundamental
right to vote
thank
all
you
five minutes for you for rebuttal hans
i really need an hour for rebuttal but
i'll try to do it in five minutes um
a couple things first of all there was a
mention of the heritage
election fraud database it has an
important caveat yeah it's got over uh
1300 proven cases of fraud and by proven
i mean somebody was
convicted in a court of law
or a judge or a state agency ordered a
new election like happened in north
carolina in 2018 because of the absentee
ballot fraud there
it is just a sampling of cases there's
no central database for this you want to
find these often small cases you got to
go to every
county courthouse in the country we
don't have the resources to do that and
we very carefully say it's just a
sampling of cases but you want to know
how much bigger this problem potentially
is
i'll give you a quick uh example of this
uh
there's an organization called the
public interest legal foundation it's a
non-profit
and they did something that nobody else
really has done they obtained
and bought in some cases the voter
registration lists of 42 states and the
voter histories from 42 states
now a lot of that information
unfortunately in voter registration
databases is pretty sparse
so they supplemented their database with
commercial data
particularly from credit agencies
you all would be scared if you knew how
much information credit agencies have on
you
the point of that was
they used the credit agency data to
obtain unique identifiers on each
registered voter in each state
that way when they compared the lists
they would know whether the john smith
born on
march 11th
in georgia was the same or a different
john smith
born on march 11 born
registered in alabama
then they compared the data so they were
not getting false positives as other
people who have tried to done this
done they released the report last year
it's called critical conditions you can
find it on their website they found over
144
000 potential cases of fraud arising out
of the 2016 and 2018 election let me
give you a quick summary of some of
these
they found 8 300 people who voted who
were registered and voted in two
different states during the 2018
election
they found
almost 8 000 deceased individuals who
the state said voted in the 2016
election and almost 7 000 who voted
in the 2018. that's our 2018 election
they found over 43 000 individuals who
are registered more than once at the
same address in the same state and voted
twice in the 2016 election
and
38 000 people registered more than once
at the same address who cast two votes
in the 2018 election now you might
wonder how that can happen that's
because election officials aren't very
good
at realizing that somebody whose name is
slightly expelled with a slight
discrepancy is actually the same person
and these individuals were able to take
advantage of that to vote twice
they found
uh 5500 individuals registered at two
different addresses in the same state
who voted twice in the 2018 election and
they found 34 000
individuals who voted
in the 2018 election
who were you remember you're supposed to
be registered where you live right
and they found them registered at
everything from a commercial addresses
such as gas stations casinos
they found vacant lots they found a mine
in nevada it's just one thing after
another like that
now the point of this is that our system
unfortunately is not
very good in catching things like that
election officials aren't very good at
it either this report's been out since
last year
not a single election official in any of
the 42 states
contacted the public interest legal
foundation and said can you send us the
data you've got on people in our states
so that we can investigate this and see
if this is valid not a single law
enforcement official
in any of those states contacted
them to say can you send us information
so we can investigate it and see if this
is correct
which shows you something that i've
encountered now for over 20 years
including when i was at the justice
department which is that unfortunately
a lot of prosecutors is not a priority
for them
when they are working on murders and
rapes and bank robberies they just don't
think this is very important
time's out yeah okay
so 30 seconds thanks okay
well we now get to the q a portion of
the evening we have a microphone just on
that side for people to line up and ask
questions
we the format also includes the
opportunity for each of you to ask the
other question at any time
eliza and hans would you pick up those
mics and make sure that
you speak clearly into them
and i
want to ask you eliza would you like to
put a question to hands at this point
i would love to hear first from the
audience okay folks have questions all
right uh and uh hands would you like to
put maybe our only agreement of the
evening
i'm gonna i'm gonna start uh with a
moderator's prerogative uh ask a
question uh eliza i take it uh
just to verify something in this case i
take it you believe that
the idea of providing identification
as with a driver's license or passport
or whatever
should not apply because it is
discriminatory against people of limited
means and time who cannot so provide
do i have that correct in your case
well you should correct me if i'm
misunderstanding the question but i
think
voter id laws are not created equally
across the country some of them are in
fact discriminatory and have been found
to be discriminatory like the 2013 law
that i mentioned out of north carolina
like a law out of texas
that was challenged and the fifth
circuit found to be discriminatory and
the texas legislature amended the law as
a result
i see okay so you're opposed to those
particular voter id laws but not
necessarily is there a particular
voter right kind of a voter id law
requiring proof of identification that
you would accept and support
i think it really depends on the
circumstances of that law what the law
provides what it enables what the
communities in the state have access to
and that's not something that
one can answer in hypothetical
empirically is there any
voter id law in any state in any area
that you say is fine and empirically
is it any are any of them fine i would
have to take a look at the particular
laws all right uh can you comment on
that hands on uh
uh i'm not sure there's any voter id law
passing any state hasn't been attacked
by various groups claiming it's
discriminatory they
have in the past claimed every
voter id law is discriminatory what you
all don't know because if you read the
new york times you wouldn't realize this
but the overwhelming majority of
lawsuits filed against state id laws
have lost
okay there's been one or two wins
a handful of wins but the overwhelming
majority of them have lost because
when it came to actually showing that
there's somebody in the state that can't
comply with it
they've been unable to do that that was
certainly the case in the georgia
lawsuit that was the case in the indiana
lawsuit where the the judges noted
in their opinions you can go find this
that the planners couldn't produce
anyone who would uh be unable to vote
because the id requirement and if you
think that's discriminatory
then obviously
groups here need to be suing the state
of new york and the city of new york
because i before i came up here i
checked the websites
and if you want to get a marriage
license in new york state
you need to prove who you are with a
driver's license passport
employment picture id or an immigration
record
okay
that's the kind of id requirement what
you need there the new york office of
temporary and disability assistance they
have a question on the website says
what proof may i need to provide to get
public assistance
well in order to prove who you are they
have the list three things
a photo id a driver's license or a us
passport
so the idea that this is somehow a
problem
is just not the case and for any and in
fact
i i i will say this
i think it is patronizingly racist to
believe that minority voters cannot
obtain a free id and if you want to see
an extraordinary statement on this
look up the testimony of the lieutenant
governor of north carolina mark robinson
first african-american elected
lieutenant governor the state of north
carolina who testified in april before
the
house judiciary committee
and gave an extraordinary uh
testimony about this and saying
i'll just give you one quote from it the
notion that people must be protected
from a free id to secure their votes is
not just insane it is insulting
thank you hans uh okay uh audience
questions uh please no need to identify
yourself and please state your question
as a question and tell us to whom it's
addressed
take it away i have a factual question
uh for for either one of you
when they have mail-in ballots or
absentee ballots
i i vote
in person do they ever compare to see if
they're been double voting under the
same name
yes they do that's what e poll books are
in polling places and that will indicate
when somebody has already voted by mail
or has requested a mail ballot
on the polling book
so when you check in to vote in person
the polling the election workers will
know that and if they see that in many
states if they see that you have in fact
voted already by mail or you've
requested a mail ballot they will ask
you to vote provisionally which means
you get to submit a ballot but it won't
count if you've already voted
uh comment from you han
just just keep in mind the effectiveness
effectiveness of that
catching somebody who's trying to vote
twice like that
depends on the efficiency of election
officials
okay and in fact i think it was last
year
the secretary of state of georgia
actually forwarded the names of a
thousand individuals
to the attorney general's office there
because they discovered after the
election
that those individuals
had voted twice they had voted with an
absentee ballot in the primary election
not the general election they had voted
twice um in person and with the absentee
ballot and the only way that could have
happened was because the election
officials in the polling place
didn't catch the fact that an absentee
ballot had already been submitted
next question
i grew up partly in europe and i'm
struck by the fact that
there are 47 countries in europe
and as of this month every single one
requires an id at the polls i'm just
wondering why
and i also note that in canada in two
weeks they're all going to vote
nationally
and even if you file a mail-in ballot or
you vote anywhere in canada you're going
to have to prove your identity is that a
question and canada well i'm just asking
since canada is
ranking much higher than the united
states by the u.n human rights records
why in the world are the canadians so
obnoxious about
these issues of voting who is that
question addressed mr fund to both okay
either of you want to take it
well i also point out that
mexico
which is a country with a much greater
uh
rate of poverty than we do actually i
think in the 1990s
put in a requirement for people to have
a photo id when they go vote and a lot
of people credit
their implementation of that id uh with
the fact that the opposition party won
for the first time in decades
uh and
we we are just kind of an outlier in the
fact that we don't require id and i will
just tell you one one quick story if i
may about this
every election you all probably know the
um
uh
european union sends election observers
actually to the united states
to observe our elections and for the
past
oh more than a decade i've been one of
the individuals asked to brief
um the observers on how the election
process works in the u.s et cetera and
i'm usually on a panel
with folks
like from the asu aclu and others who
are sitting there talking about
voter id and how terrible it is and the
reaction of the observers is always like
they don't really understand why that's
an issue because in every single one of
their countries they have to show an id
to vote
comment from you uh elijah yes well
certainly i'm not going to comment on
the character of canadians um but
but one thing i will note again
is that voter id has not been shown to
be correlated with preventing fraud or
the lack of voter id requirements has
not been correlated
or shown to have any relationship to the
existence or presence of fraud and we
live in a country where we don't
automatically provide national id's to
people so there is a big difference in
terms of the international context that
we're operating
and i think given those things you have
to wonder why are states trying to put
voter id laws in place if we don't have
data showing that it's helping our
election integrity and people have to go
out and affirmatively get id
and in another example of uh somebody
saying the quiet part out loud and
this is you know back in 2011
pennsylvania's then republican house
leader um said that the state's new id
law which was in fact struck down by the
pennsylvania supreme court was going to
quote allow governor romney to win the
state of pennsylvania so these are
provisions that are being put in place
specifically to make it harder to vote
without the data to show that they
actually improve our elections
um maybe you'll respond i see hans
shaking his head so i'll give him a
chance to shake his head verbally and
then you can respond go ahead yes
uh
i wrote a paper ten years ago i'd urge
you all to read it it's called stolen
identities stolen votes a case study and
voter impersonation do you all remember
elizabeth holtzman
former democratic congresswoman right
and she became the district attorney in
kings county when she came back right
in the mid-1980s she convened a state
grand jury and she released the report
of the grand jury
most of you know grandeur usually
operate in secret so it was
extraordinary that she released this
public
report of the grand jury let me tell you
what the grand jury found in kings
county brooklyn
she found that for 14 years
a voter fraud conspiracy had occurred in
kings county
successfully without detection
in which
the practices included the forgery of
voter registration cards with the names
of fictitious persons the filing of
those cards with the board of elections
the recruitment of people to cast
multiple votes on behalf of specified
candidates using those forged names as
well as
the registrations of deceased
and other persons and your point hands
is that as that voter id could have
dealt with that is that what you're
saying the grand jury recommended at the
end of it that the state should
consider putting in an id requirement
because that could have potentially
prevented i'm sure you've read that
paper eliza and i'm sure you know what
the problem is with it could you tell us
yeah
i i
can see that i have not read the paper
recently
but again i would say that the data is
not there to back up the efficacy of
voter id with respect to voter fraud the
data is there to show that these
instances are extraordinarily rare
and again i i would urge you to do a
cost-benefit analysis
of the costs and burdens on voters when
you impose restrictions and the benefit
that you get out of them
and i also want to make sure folks are
thinking not just about voter id that's
not the only kind of restriction that
states are putting in place this year
once again they are making it harder to
vote by mail making harder to drop off
your mail ballot shortening early voting
periods making it harder to throw out
intimidating poll watchers from from a
polling place
there is a wide range of restrictions
that states are enacting this year and
it's quite clear what the overall trend
shows
uh next question
i got something i've been wondering
about that maybe you can help me with
either or both of you there's a large
number of people in this country quite
remarkably large like in the millions
who are completely mentally incapable of
voting and i'm talking about people with
alzheimer's
and people with what's called
developmental disabilities used to be
called mentally [ __ ] but put the two
of them together it's in the millions
first of all as far as i know they're
entitled to vote if they're over 21
maybe you can uh answer that for me and
and my second question is
if you if you take like the people with
alzheimer's or tend to be in nursing
homes and they're probably registered to
vote because they were once capable of
voting what's to keep the person who
runs the nursing home or their their
friendly
political operative from rounding up
ballots from all those people filling
them out having them sign up dropping
dropping them back off is there any
control on that whatsoever
you get to i'm sorry go ahead look
unless a court declares you legally
incompetent you have a right to vote
but
um
the an example of someone trying to take
advantage of this is that last summer
a woman who works in a state supported
home for the developmentally challenged
in texas
was indicted
because the individuals who were there
were had all been declared legally
incompetent that's why they were in this
particular
this particular home she was indicted
because she was filling out and
completing voter registration forms for
all of them i i think the number was
like 140 of them that she had submitted
basically filling it out signing
their names
and it clearly she was she was going to
then uh request absentee ballots and
vote them in their case the problem in
nursing homes is an acute problem
that's that's
you may not recall this but there was a
congressman from pennsylvania who about
20 years ago was in fact
criminally charged for doing exactly
that going into nursing homes to
obtain uh obtain and vote absentee
ballots from individuals there but
you're not opposed to people with
alzheimer's voting as long as they're
ideas if they are unless they've been
declared legally incompetent they have a
right to vote what needs to happen
though is
local election officials and the local
parties
need to do a better job of for example
example what ought to happen is
they ought to set up
a polling day like an early voting day
in a nursing home
where people will be able to vote there
will be election officials there to
supervise it and there'll be observers
there
from the democratic party republican
party libertarian party green party to
make sure that the it's the residents by
themselves
making the the decision on who to vote
for and you don't have staff and other
people basically filling out the ballot
and signing their name and submitting it
but you need better supervision of the
any comments of your lives are better
yeah i mean i think the um the the
answer to your question is in what hans
just described which is that woman was
indicted in texas and what what you're
what the anecdote reveals is that there
was fraud being committed against
americans not fraud being committed by
the voters themselves
there are criminal prohibitions against
that kind of misconduct they are working
they are resulting in criminal
prosecutions
the kinds of restrictions that we are
seeing enacted this year banning
curbside voting shortening early voting
periods those kinds of restrictions
don't solve that problem they just make
it harder for eligible americans to cast
their ballots in a convenient method
next question
for those
laws that have either been uh presented
or passed since the 2020 election um do
you have the breakdown on the states um
where i guess the sponsors of those
bills whether you know which side of the
aisle they fell on
the
laws that are being enacted to that the
brandon center characterizes as making
it harder for americans to vote are
being enacted are being introduced
predominantly by republican sponsors and
are be and are being enacted in large
part
virtually on party lines comment uh bad
hand hands
no comment next question
hello my name is chloe um i have two
questions but i only asked one um my
question is for the gentleman so i read
the supreme court decision
regarding arizona
and the minority opinion specifically
brought up the issue of native american
communities having a precedent with
having a member of their tribe deliver
mail-in ballots to officials and that is
no longer allowed in arizona
and i'm just wondering if you had any
thoughts on that because you brought up
the potential fraud with third party
third parties collecting votes
but there is no evidence of fraud
happening particularly in this community
and there's also precedent for this
community being allowed to
do this kind of
delivery of voting just because of the
way their communities are set up so just
curious to know your thoughts
just so you all know what we're talking
about the the arizona case was called
bronovich versus dnc
and the issue in that case there were
two issues
one is uh the state like more than half
of the states across the country ban
what i call vote trafficking third
unrelated third parties being able to
pick up and deliver ballots because of
the potential danger from that
california actually for a long time
banned it they only legalized it a
couple of years ago
the second issue in arizona
was the fact that for decades they've
had the same rule that is the rule in
almost every other state which is you
have to vote in the precinct to which
you're assigned
okay there's two important reasons for
that
one
if you don't vote if you vote in your
precinct they're going to be able to
vote for
all the offices for which you're
qualified not just president and
and u.s senator but local city council
and county commission raises state
legislative races
if the state says well you can go vote
anywhere then you may end up in a
precinct where
you may be able to vote for the top of
the ticket but you can't vote for all
the rest so in effect
you're get you're going to be
disenfranchising folks
are you specifically addressing the
young ladies and on the on the vote
harvesting thing
one of the reasons the court said
the state can do this is because
arizona actually has one of the most
expansive
ways to vote there they have long period
of early voting
they have a long period of absentee
balloting and this one restriction
in fact the dnc was able unable to
produce any evidence
that it was going to keep anyone from
being able to vote
right uh congratulations yeah i think
that
particularly that example reflects um
what we see all over the country was
which is that voting restrictions can
burden certain communities more than
others and that's why it's so important
to look beyond the top line voter
turnout numbers and see who is affected
by these kinds of laws this arizona case
the brnovich decision is the one in
which
the arizona state republican party
lawyer said the reason why we need these
laws on the books is because we want to
win elections that there was really a
partisan interest
that this had nothing to do with
election integrity um but and i should
note that with respect to out of
precinct voting many states do allow you
to vote out of precinct but they only
allow you to vote a provisional ballot
and you only get to vote your votes only
count for the races for which you're
qualified so only for senate and
president not for city council if you're
in the wrong place
next question
thank you um first i'd just like to say
i couldn't agree with you more on the
importance of civil debate and i'd like
to thank you both for being here in that
spirit uh to take us back to the
resolution which is um that legislators
are actively working to suppress voter
uh suppressed voters um i'd like to my
question is for the gentleman i was
hoping that he could address directly
the
other
voter restrictions that the that the
lady mentioned um not including voter id
which i think we've covered pretty
thoroughly uh specifically fewer ballot
boxes fewer drop-offs uh drive-in voting
uh cut cutting down on early voting days
um and a how those are not making it
harder to vote and b even if they're not
making harder to vote in what way are
they justified
sure um what texas did is they actually
said
uh
curbside voting can only be used by
somebody who is disabled and can't make
it into a polling place
okay and that's the rule in the vast
majority of states so i don't think it's
somehow keeping people from voting
uh if you ban curbside voting for anyone
unless they're disabled if you're
disabled
you can drive up in your car the
election official will come out that's
the standard rule in in in many states
um so i don't think it's a problem given
the fact that if you're
able to get into a polling place
particularly early voting day with early
voting analytic on election day i don't
think that's a problem
look the problem with dropboxes is what
what they have said is they're going to
have a if you're going to have a dropbox
it's got to be a dropbox that is secured
under surveillance
it can't just be a drop box out on the
street that anyone can access here's the
way to look at that
okay
does anybody in here think it would be a
good idea
if uh what you go and you vote in a
precinct uh you drop your paper ballot
into the ballot box you leave
at the end of the day
what states uh what what happens in
states that use paper ballots like that
is
the election official
seals the box
he puts it in his car with the assistant
manager and they drive the box of sealed
ballots downtown to the election
headquarters
where it's then opened and counted
do you all think anybody in here think
would be a good idea to take that ballot
box which is filled with something
valuable
ballots
and the the precinct manager simply went
and put it out on the street
and left it unattended
and said well somebody will be by here
in a while to pick it up i don't think
anybody agree with that that would be a
good idea well that's what dropboxes are
and
the problems with them could be
everything from people uh stealing the
box to what happened last year you may
have seen prior to the election when
some mailboxes
were set on fire that contained
apparently absentee ballots like in
richmond and the postal service had to
send out a notice saying
if if you dropped an absentee ballot in
this mailbox
you'd need to check on it because it may
have been destroyed that's the problem
with
with drop boxes as long as they're
under surveillance they're guarded so
that kind of thing can't happen that's
not a problem and that's what texas has
said
um
okay
comment yes i think context is key
so
while
it is true that in texas if you have a
disability you can still vote curbside
this law was enacted after counties in
texas allowed drive-through voting last
year because of the risks of gathering
during the pandemic
and
voters turned out in record numbers in
harris county where that policy was
implemented and then lo and behold we
see a policy that bans drive-through and
curbside voting for all voters and again
you have to ask why just because it's
still allowed for voters with
disabilities why should it not be
allowed for other voters if there has
been no proven problem with that method
of voting
likewise context is key when considering
dropboxes dropboxes have been used
largely without incident in states
across the country for many many years
this is the first year where we are
seeing laws limit the availability of
drop boxes and that's because lots of
voters used them last year
and
just as you can drop a your mail ballot
off in any blue mailbox on the corner
which is not monitored which is not
staffed that's the way that drop boxes
have largely operated in states across
the country very successfully and again
that's the kind of convenience
measure that makes it easier for people
to vote and therefore increases turnout
because that convenience that the
proximity to where you vote actually has
been shown to increase turnout and
increasing that distance from where you
vote has been shown to decrease turnout
so there's lots of data on this showing
that these are successful policies
uh
good question
okay so um this is primarily for ms
swearin becker so uh you said on a few
occasions that we don't have data about
the connection between these measures or
the lack of them and fraud are there
cases where even in the absence of data
even in uncertainty we should still act
one way because
you know
the consequences of not doing this
though we don't know that they will
happen they could and that there might
be a low cost so that we should still
take such measures
thank you and thank you for dating to
pronounce my last name which i know is a
mouthful so i appreciate that um i think
that the data that we do have shows that
the risks are very low and we're dealing
with
one of if not the most precious right in
a free society and i think we both agree
on the on the value of that right to
vote
and so when you're talking about
measures that make it harder to exercise
that most fundamental right
you need a really good reason to make
that more difficult and i don't think we
have the data to show that what we do
have the data to show is that these
risks are infinitesimally small and
don't justify taking those measures that
haven't been shown to be helpful in the
first place
uh comment tense
oh your wife well i'll just say i just i
just don't i just don't agree with it uh
the u.s has a long history of election
fraud especially unfortunately in new
york city
and
to just to tell you quickly how easy it
is to cheat in this city i suggest all
of you google and find a report put out
by the new york
department of investigations after the
2013 de blasio election
they did an investigation of the
election department
because they got
two complaints one that everyone in the
board elections was high they were
hiring their family which you're not
supposed to do
but second that they weren't doing
anything to maintain the accuracy of the
voter list
and to test this on election day they
sent their undercover agents into new
york precincts all over the city
and got their undercover agents to ask
for the ballots of individuals who were
dead
had moved away or otherwise uh
ineligible to vote because they were
still on the voter list and they tried
to make it as obvious as possible the
best example i recall was one of the
undercover age as a young
african-american woman in her 20s she
went in and asked for the ballot of a
woman who was still registered to vote
who was in her 80s caucasian was dead
in every single case they were handed
the ballot without question
so they could have voted the ballot and
there was only one person who was caught
and that person was caught because they
went in and asked for the ballot of an
individual who is currently in the state
penitentiary and therefore can't vote
and it so happened that the woman
working at the registration desk was the
prisoner's mother and realized that was
not her son
we now move to the uh summation portion
of the evening uh uh eliza uh your
summation your five minute summation
take the podium eliza oh i was not aware
that we had a five five-minute summation
i'm
sure that you've got a lot to say anyway
um
as i mentioned off mike i was not aware
that we had a five-minute submission so
i have nothing particularly prepared um
but i think i would just
refer all of you back to the resolution
which is that state lawmakers across the
country are actively working to make it
harder for americans to vote
i haven't heard anything today that
disproves that what we have seen our
policies enacted dozens of policies
enacted just this year that cut back on
early voting that cut back on mail
voting that cut back on disability
access
and and these policies have been proven
time and time again to make it harder to
vote these are precisely the policies
that states many states adopted for the
first time last year or that voters took
advantage of in record numbers last year
in order to vote safely during the
pandemic and now those policies are the
target of these state lawmakers because
we've seen so many people turn out
and nothing i've heard today shows that
shows that state lawmakers
or that many state lawmakers are not
making it trying to make it harder for
vote eligible voters to cast their
ballots and again i would urge you all
to look behind the overall turnout
numbers from the 2020 election and see
what see what lawmakers are actually
trying to do
because it matters what their motivation
is it matters that there are efforts
being undertaken by state lawmakers to
undermine our democracy to undermine
americans participation to undermine our
faith in the electoral system without
being based on particular data to
substantiate those laws
five minutes
just one quick thing i keep hearing
early voting days cut back that was
actually claim made about the georgia
reform bill we even heard joe biden make
it that is absolutely false
you can look at the bill you can see
that they did not reduce the number of
early voting days and in fact
they have about the same average number
uh that other states do in fact texas
was one of the first states in the
entire united states to put in early
voting
they still have more early voting than
the state of new york
they have more early voting than the
state of delaware which currently has no
early voting and i don't seem to hear
anyone
saying we're going to have to sue new
york and delaware because
they have less early voting days and
delaware has none they have passed
a law they're going to start having it
in 2022 but it still will be fewer days
then texas and and georgia
it is important that we
maintain the security of our elections
it can be done and it's been shown to be
done
by now 13 years worth of data you know
everybody's talking as if the only
election reforms ever passed when this
it's past legislative session no
as i said the first voter id laws were
passed in 2005 in georgia indiana other
states have been putting them in over
the years everywhere from
north carolina to arizona to other
states and in that entire time turnout
has just been going up and registration
has been going up and if you doubt me
on that issue
here's something else for you to google
pull up the 20
the u.s census report on the 2020
election
we had the biggest turnout in
last year's election in
this century
and it was the second highest turnout
according to the census bureau since the
92 election so this entire time where
people have been doing things like
putting in id laws to try to prevent
fraud registration and turnout have been
going up and the attitudes about this
show this ex like i said this
extraordinarily patronizing attitude
towards the american public
as if for example they can't deal with
the free getting a free id
i want to end by quoting uh former
president jimmy carter and former
secretary of state james baker
in 2005 they issued a report this was
after the
florida election
they formed a commission on federal
election reform
and they said this which i think is
extraordinarily correct
uh and by the way one of the things that
both jimmy carter and james baker in the
report recommended was voter id
elections are the heart of democracy
they are the instrument for the people
to choose leaders and hold them
accountable
at the same time elections are a core
public function upon which all other
government responsibilities depend if
elections are defective the entire
democratic system is at risk
i agree with that and i don't think we
should put it at risk by
having a system that makes it easy
for people to
vote without authenticating their
identity
without authenticating their citizenship
that makes it easy for them to register
in two different states
and not get caught because states don't
do a good job of comparing their voter
lists
and while in some cases it might just be
one person cheating
like the student we just added to our
database who was prosecuted he's a
resident of massachusetts
he's going to the university of new
hampshire and he voted in both states
illegally
or if it's a group of individuals who
have acted together to steal an election
like the half dozen individuals who were
criminally charged in north carolina
in the congressional race that was
overturned because of their fraud we
should be concerned about it
and we can do things
to make sure that doesn't happen at the
same time
that we allow and make it possible for
eligible americans to vote
access
does not prevent security and security
does not prevent access thank you very
much
[Music]
well it was an interesting uh heat
the yes votes began with a little over
31
and uh ended with 44 percent took up and
gained more than 13 points
and that's the number to beat the no
votes uh
gained uh gained 18 points so beat the
that by five points the tootsie roll
therefore goes to the negative
congratulations to you
both you